so there's an anecdote I sometimes tell
for a laugh when I'm just uh speaking
somewhere randomly but it it took place
here so I'll tell it again here right
around the turn of the Millennium I
turned 40 I was born in 1960 and I was
uh lecturing in this building
and a
freshman walked in the room and looked
at me and said Jaron lanir you're still
alive I was like oh
God computer science is a little rough
on you you know he's just mov so fast
and so anyway y still going here
um so uh I wrote a book last year very
rapidly Mo most people take off time to
write a book I somehow did it working
overnights and on weekends while I was
uh running other research projects uh
but it somehow got done it's called WS
the future and it's about the
relationship between technology and
employment technology and human roles
and particularly uh computational
technology uh so I'm going to share with
you a summary view of it the full
picture is a little bit too complex to
get into one talk but I think I can
summarize
it uh so let me start by recalling the
excitement that I'm sure some of the
people in this room will recall very
vividly but if you're younger you you
won't have been born yet um but the
excitement that that
uh arose around anticipation of
networking before it actually worked
before it existed so going back uh I was
a teach teenager in the 70s and that's
when I really started interacting with
people about it and this notion that
someday there would be a way that
information could just move around
between people quickly and cheaply was
just an astonishing idea it was
something so novel so remarkable and so
profound that of course we still just
marvel at it all the time and a lot of
our culture seems to be sort of self-
congratulatory at this point about the
fact that the thing actually works um
but a part of that for me was a sort of
uh uh Imagining the good that would come
of it uh and that good would take place
on various levels for instance uh my
friends and I at the time my my comrades
in this in this uh Quest believed that
this would uh create tremendous Economic
Opportunity that all kinds of people
would find ways to improve themselves
improve their lives when they had more
open access to information we also
thought that it would serve as a kind of
an inoculation against extreme power
concentration if you look at the history
of how people treat each other badly the
recurring pattern is that somebody gets
powerful and treats masses of people
terribly and the first thing they try to
do is control communication they try to
control whatever the channels of
communication are in the era in which
they're being a creep whether that's a
TV station or the printing press or or
or whatever and so the notion was well
if you have an open information system
it ought to make that pattern uh become
more diffuse we so we're quite certain
we're doing good things for the world I
was I was part of um the generation that
invented some of the rhetoric that's
really become um standard at this point
uh last night I got in from New York
City I spoke at the United Nations
General Assembly about this stuff this
week and it's remarkable to to me to
hear heads of state from around the
world uh the new cliches that they just
parrot about technology and the future
and the internet and openness are the
stuff we made up in cafes and Palo Alto
30 years ago you know a BN a bunch of
nerell hippie you know freaky geeky kids
you know and then now this stuff is just
the standard rhetoric um and uh I I
found myself in a bit of a personal
crisis around the turn of the century
the same time I that this student was
surprised I still existed um uh because
I felt that much of I anticipated was
not playing out as anticipated uh I'll
give you a couple of examples one of
them is that uh I'd been uh very much
part of the early movement to encourage
uh file copying and open sharing of
information uh and and being suspicious
of uh copyright
law and I'm also a musician a
professional musician and I was certain
that if we we allowed music to FL flow
freely and through cop file copying that
what that would result in is more
opportunity that uh that you know
clinging to this old business model was
silly and shortsighted I was and so I
helped make up a lot of the rhetoric
that still is extremely commonplace and
is held dearly by many people but what I
started to see around the turn of the
century is that actually musicians were
doing worse and worse now of course
there's still some who do very well at
the very typ top of a of a power law
curve but what I was seeing is that what
had been a middle hump what had been a
uh approximately a standard distribution
of outcomes was was turning into a
hollowed out distribution with uh or
what we call long tail um a lot of
wannabes and only a few people who
succeeded and this hit me pretty hard in
a in a in a special way which is that uh
there were um quite a large number I'd
say a whole generation of musicians who
had been enormously successful and
revered and well not enormously
successful but you know for they weren't
like Superstars they weren't Michael
Jacksons but they were people who had um
gotten into the upper middle class at
the very least and and were famous and
were cherished but uh in in later in
life they hadn't been able to hold on to
health insurance in the US they'd lost
their homes and it was getting to the
point where every week I was being asked
to get involved in some emergency
fundraiser at a jazz club or something
and I started to realize this isn't just
a few exceptions this is the pattern and
so what I started to do was try to
gather real data on what was actually
happening to the people that I thought
we were helping and I found something
that was really kind of extraordinary to
me uh one thing is that the number of
people who were making a good living
under the in the era of copyright was
actually larger than IID realized in the
United States there were almost a third
of a million musicians making over
$100,000 a year which isn't it's not as
good as have you know it's not like
selling Instagram to Facebook or
something but it's a very nice living
you can live well on that certainly um
we might forget that in Silicon Valley
but that's considered that's considered
success in most of the world and um uh
and that number had been driven down to
by 2/3 within just about 5 years there's
a total collapse and it seems to be
added to much less than that it's
continuing to drop and um meanwhile uh
there was this there's this mythology
that they all these musicians who are
coming up and um doing great by uh
creating unconventional careers using uh
Network Technology where they promote
themselves they get fans to show up and
and and there when you people just
assume there must be a replacement Force
that's coming in so what I thought is
well if the if the New Wave is not being
captured by the old measurements which
wouldn't be surprising let's try to
measure the new wave and see what's
really going on and so I started to try
to count individual musicians who were
being successful and I did everything I
could think of to do it I went to every
kind of business that might cater to
them um and I know musicians I mean I
tried and I went on the popular sites
that support this point of view like the
boing boings and whatnot and I called
out if you have any stories of somebody
doing this send them to me I tried to
find them and when I wrote my previous
book which was published a few years ago
the number I came up with was about five
individuals uh I mean it's just it's
basically they exist they're real and I
think
today if you're willing to really relax
your standards we might be getting up
into the low hundreds on a global basis
and in the US maybe 50ish so you know
it's ramping up but we're not seeing
thousands hundreds of thousands millions
we're seeing a very small phenomenon and
and they're tenuous what's interesting
is the ones that I found a few years ago
of those only one is still maintaining a
career today and so so the thing is that
this this sense that there's this
counter force of of people who are
creating a living in a new way is
actually a fiction it's a very popular
Fiction it's kind of like the satanists
who steal babies or something like it's
this thing a lot of people believe is
out there but they are not actually out
there um uh there are a lot of there are
people who pretend to be them and it
took a little bit of work to try to
figure out what was real and what wasn't
but they're people who pay to create the
illusion that they're making a living
this way because it's fashionable and
then in order to figure out who's
authentic and who's not sometimes you
can just ask them and sometimes it takes
a bit more work but in terms of
clear-cut examples they're very very
very rare um what is not rare at all is
somebody who's extremely wellestablished
in the traditional system doing
something like a giveway on the internet
for publicity so if you're um radio head
or or um or something like that that
works great and there's a lot of
examples of that that's I don't think
that should count that's a publicity
thing and they still count on their they
still count on the traditional system
for their money anyway so um so a just
in terms of musicians I found myself
disappointed in the economic results so
then I wanted to look at well you know
what if it's just musicians and
journalists and photographers if it's
certain specific classes which are the
people who are sort of dealing with
information uh anyway if it's the
communicators if it's those people
that's okay cuz we can create
institutions to support them we can
create new institutions to support
investigative journalists we can we can
compensate Society can can make can
figure that out that's an acceptable
failure uh because if it's part of a
greater success so that's where I was at
for a
while but then I started to uh I I've
been I've been quite involved in
technologies that could throw masses of
people people out of work myself you
know and I realized I think what struck
me one day is I was at one meeting in
Silicon Valley where we were talking
about how to train people to um how how
can we use uh internet Technologies and
mobile technologies to train people in
underdeveloped parts of the world so
they can have jobs and the kinds of jobs
we were going to train them in were um
service manufacturer some agricultural
this different kinds of things like this
but then that same day I went to another
me meeting where we were creating
robotss that would do all the same stuff
and if we chart the course the expected
course of the Improvement of those
robots it's really pretty clear that any
solution we could come up with for using
our Network Technologies to train people
would be very temporary because we'd
probably have a decade at most and
probably a lot less before we made our
training Obsolete and so some any
solution would have to have a very
different form so uh I I became very
interested in this problem and I've
talked to all kinds of people with all
kinds of points of view on it all kinds
of different
economists um and I've developed my own
opinion about where the solution space
could be uh some people find it quite
radical uh I've got I've um my last book
I think is distinguished by having
perhaps the most positive and just ulent
EXA reviews I've seen in major
Publications about any book I mean the
New York Times book is reviewing it as
if it's the new Bible or something and
then I've also gotten perhaps the worst
reviews I've ever seen so the Washington
Post review was treating it as like the
worst book ever so I have this
incredibly wide range of responses which
I which I like a lot better than
uniformly positive ones um so let me
present to you uh the position I've come
to which is still in flux and not Sacred
By Any Means
question presented uhhuh you said there
was 300,000 musicians making a living
doing music in the 1980s roughly no at
the turn of the century turn of century
2000 turn of the okay well
um what were most of them doing were
they the this was performing musicians
who uh who were uh whose income was
substantially royalty driven so these
were people yeah so uh this is not this
was and and and the reason you tell is
because in in uh in tax records it falls
in different categories so you can
actually find those
people live performing people would get
wiped out by records which they sort of
did and then so yeah yeah before you all
right before you give me the argument
about how it's always the people have
always been displaced in Creative
destruction let me I want to go through
that in great detail and and to do that
since you brought up John Philip Souza I
would like to use that as a segue to
speak about the 19th century
if I may um so uh so uh I I'd like to
present an overly simplified view of the
history of technology and employment and
economics in the form of a melodrama and
three acts and I'm obviously
tremendously oversimplifying and
there'll be all kinds of exceptions but
I just want to try to give a very quick
picture um so I want to start with the
19th century that's act one and then
we'll do the second act is the 20th
century and the third Act is our Century
the 21st century um the 19th century was
an extraordinarily future oriented
period uh if you go into the literature
of the 19th century you find uh a
tremendous emphasis on what the future
will be like what the what the
definition of a person will be what
human roles will be like and also what
technology will be like um I'm going to
mention just a few of the key moments in
this uh in this 19th century of
obsession with technology um I think a
good starting point is the Lite riots um
and so the the I'm sure people here
would be familiar with that but in case
you're not these were uh riots in London
connect uh conducted by textile workers
who were concerned that improving
textile machinery would throw them out
of work they were ugly riots and they
ended in
executions um they weren't
anti-technology per se but uh they they
were they expressed um this intense fear
that when somebody moves to the city
from the countryside and they're
dependent on an institution for their
living instead of just the land then if
that institution is going to shift
around unpredictably they feel terribly
insecure and will become violent to
protect their position and that was kind
of a new thing um but let me mention a
couple of other interesting 19th century
things starting in the 1840s a writer
named Carl Marx largely inspired by the
Lite riots and similar ones started
writing about technology and if you read
the early marks before before he was
trying to turn into Hegel he was a
technology writer who would have ended
up as a kick-ass editor-in-chief of wir
or something and um I discovered this
one day when I was listening to kpfa the
Lefty station from Berkeley while
driving and I heard what I thought was a
description of a new Silicon Valley
startup where saying we're going to make
we're going to we're going to create
such efficiencies that there will no
longer be Market barriers and we're
going to about and I was kind like oh my
God not one of I can't listen to more of
this stuff and I was going try this has
been an anniversary reading of Marxism
like so I went back and read Marx and
Marx really had a start as a technology
writer and his his his concern was very
explicitly what happens to people he's a
Moors law framed person from well before
computation or Moors law he's saying
we're not living in a time of constancy
we're living in a time where technology
is ramping up and the better technology
gets the the more people's roles will
have to change and at some point when
the machines can do a lot of stuff what
do all the people do
and and he and he said you know is there
are there going to be just a tiny
minority that benefit from the machines
or will everybody benefit from the
machines and now Marx Marx is a sort of
um I don't know how to put this
anymore there's no nice way to say this
he his ideas were for what to do were
crap I mean he he really suggested ideas
that led to some of the most brutal
regimes in in in modernity so I'm
absolutely not supportive of his ideas
for what to do about it and he also was
um
he was also a fantasist he had this idea
that when the machines got good we'd all
live in in classically manicured Lawns
and practice archery and read the
classics in other words everyone was
supposed to live in his Heaven which is
exactly the problem with the Socialist
Utopia that you have somebody deciding
what's good for everybody so problematic
in terms of his ideas for Solutions but
his articulation about the problem was
uh extraordinarily preent and and really
I think astonishing for its time um
another thing that was born in the 19th
century that we still still live with
his science fiction science fiction
started off as a way to contemplate what
people would do when the robots got good
if you look at uh science fiction is
always about what what people will be
like um or will people become obsolete
or not that's the question science
fiction asks and we might be made
obsolete by a superior alien or by our
own machines those are the two options
It's usually the machines that and if
just what I said covers all the scripts
recently it covers uh let's go through
them Battle Star Galactica Terminator
Matrix blah blah blah it's always the
same thing over and over again a really
good 19th century example is the time
machine B HG Wells where Humanity uh
bifurcates into two species and the rich
ones are the descendants of people who
had successful IPOs here and then the
poor ones are farmed and eaten by them
and they're both miserable ultimately
and it's kind it's interesting novel um
uh the how there aren't that many folk
songs from the 19th Century that we
still remember today but the ballot of
John Henry is one and it's about a guy
who's uh racing with a robot that lays
down railroad tracks and he beats the
robot but only by working so hard that
he dies of exhaustion tragically at the
end of the song so that's the 19th
century so a a really interesting
question is why didn't the Calamity
appear why was there still employment in
the 20th century and here I think the
answer comes from a very interesting
dual process um one process Came From
Below and had a left equality and
another came from on top and had a kind
of a industrialists point of view uh
quality and they they came together and
converged on a
solution so let's talk about the Lefty
the labor unions first now um whenever
you talk about this problem of whether
um people might lose work because of
Technology um a very typical response is
oh you just don't like cre cretive
destruction and think about buggy whips
you would have defended the buggy whip
industry and the buggy whip industry was
a big industry at one point and uh I
might mention that it was centered in
Rochester New York which recovered from
the loss of buggy whips by developing
the photography companies Kodak and
Polaroid that are now bankrupt and
Instagram was sold for a billion dollars
when it had 13 employees hopefully some
of them uh Stanford graduates who will
give generously or something I have no
idea but
anyway the uh um uh but anyway let's go
back to the buggy whip era I don't how
many of you have actually dealt with
horses how many how many of you ridden
horses or raced them so horses are great
aren't they they're just wonderful
animals but if you had a job where every
day you were given some horse not of
your choosing and you had to deal with
it you had to you had to brush it you
had to deal with not getting kicked by
it you had to deal with its poop every
day you'd be pretty unhappy right it's
hard that would not be an easy day's
work um so this idea of the automobile
the automatic motion machine where you
just get in and you do this and it moves
I mean my God we pay for that experience
we pay to have nice sports cars we love
it so there if you go back to the
literature during the transition years
from horses to Automobiles and trucks uh
one of the things that was often said is
well if somebody's going to be driving
one of these automatic Horseless
machines why the hell should they be
paid that's fun that's easy they're not
covered in poop and they're not at risk
of getting kicked and they're they're
living in luxury why should they get
paid it's a really interesting question
and uh and and yet we have teamsters and
cabbies and all these people so how did
that happen so as I mentioned there two
processes that came together the labor
union fought really hard to uh to to
create jobs even if those jobs were not
so miserable that uh you know even if
they were less dangerous or miserable
than previous jobs from older Tech
Generations now this is an interesting
challenge because if if the job's really
easy and you can just sit there and earn
money why wouldn't everybody want to do
it and why wouldn't there be a spiral to
the bottom in terms of wages just like
we see on Mechanical Turk or something
today right why wouldn't that happen uh
and so in order to create wages despite
the fact that the work wasn't miserable
or dangerous they instituted really
awkward bureaucratic
inefficient
corruptible exception cases and so these
were called um licenses or union
membership or um certificates or or
whatever there was this whole weird
structure of ad hoc uh little latches
that you could achieve to keep other
people out of the job and uh I call them
levies in the book like the little uh
dams that keep water uh in a in a in a
irrigation system now
um this is a really perfect system I
should mention that even though it has a
much older origin academic tenure was
one of these in the 20th century so um
don't don't feel yourselves not to be a
part of this you very much are uh on so
anyway
um uh so that was the labor movement and
it it it it at at uh with tremendous
effort created a sense of wages even for
jobs that weren't miserable meanwhile
what's what's fascinating I believe that
that in itself wouldn't have worked uh
Henry by itself I think it was an
essential but not sufficient process
Henry Ford the great entrepreneur of
making buggy whips obsolete um was by
the way a racist bastard but let's get
that out of the way he was also a
successful entrepreneur he was uh
perhaps even more than what Steve Jobs
was to us recently he was an
extraordinary man of his time in terms
of of building uh industry and uh one of
the things he said is that there cannot
be a market economy without customers
which seems quite obvious and so he said
if we're building our product base if
we're building our industry we have to
build customers or we will have no
industry and so the idea was that the
Model T and the other early cars had to
be built in such a way that they could
be afforded by the people who made them
and their way he had to set wage
standards in the whole economy starting
with his own Factory such that people
could afford the products they were
building so he had to so in a very weird
way that neither of them would ever
admit CU they would certainly hate each
other's guts these two forces of
necessity actually work towards the same
goal which is really an extra it's an
extraordinary marriage of convenience
that that nobody would ever admit to so
both of those things took place um and
uh this by the way something that always
amazes me when I talk there's a
tremendous fascination with iron ran
style libertarianism in Silicon Valley
of course and I say well how can you
have a market economy without a customer
class you know it just won't work you
know you have to have have some kind of
a bell curve distribution if you have
only successful entrepreneurs and nobody
to use their products it falls apart but
we'll we'll get back to that all right
so now we've made it to the 20th
century now we come to the turn of the
century we come to the 21st century and
in my view right around the turn of the
century kind of on the mark uh Silicon
Valley made a decision to renounce the
Covenant that had made the 20th century
work and decide you know what by the
time computation is getting so cheap
that that all the stuff's just there in
your pocket or something at that point
you don't get paid I mean for God's
sakes that's just too easy so we're not
going to pay people anymore that that's
approximately what happened um I um now
I should say it's not our fault what
what had really happened is that in the
previous couple decades two or three
decades um some other Industries had
discovered something about computation
that we were actually slow to get CU
when it comes to capitalism silicon valy
was actually a little slow I got to say
um early on financiers realized hey if
you have a big computer you can just use
it to out compute everybody else and
make just pull money out of the market I
mean for God's sake so so we'll get big
computers so from very early on when
computer as soon as Mo's law allowed
computers to be big enough for anything
to happen it did happen on Wall Street
so we had the first flash crash not
recently but in ' 87 way early in mors
law curve compared to now um how many of
you know what long-term Capital
Management was so I'm not seeing too
many hands of young people go up
congratulations sir um but I will say to
young people if you're Americans and
actually even if you're not Americans
you really should know about this
because you will be paying for it your
whole lives so you might as well know
what you're paying
for what kids and your kids yeah so what
it was is it was one of the early
schemes where somebody used massive
amounts of computation to try to find
slight advantages using just statistics
and and uh uh just uh inference and
projection to optimize investments in
the marketplace just to pull money out
of it and it was done with great Fanfare
they had a bunch of uh Nobel laurates
and economics as advisor so that it
would look very proper and they got a
bunch of money in now there's an
interesting thing about computation and
economics which is it all right no let
me just say a couple of extremely basic
truths okay it's an extremely basic
truth that
uh statistical projection will be valid
for a smoothly changing variable in
reality for a time right that's you know
if there's something smoothly varying
and you're charting it you'll be able to
predict it a little bit the problem is
that lacking any underlying Theory you
don't know for how long you'll be able
to okay now there's a very fashionable
idea in some quarters I hope not here
that because we have such big computers
now we don't really need science and
Theory anymore because we can just use
statistics and pred rejection for
instance a guy who's a friend of mine
and lives lives as my neighbor actually
uh who was the editor-in chief of wired
for a long time Chris Anderson wrote a
famous essay a few years ago which was
called something like the end of science
or the end of theory and the idea was
that we just use big computation to uh
to correlate and extrapolate and we
don't really need this whole idea of
theory and scientists and all this stuff
we just have computation but the problem
with that is that reality is not some
big continuous smoothly varying thing
reality has structure and if you can't
talk about that structure you have
absolutely no way of knowing for how
long your your purely statistically
derived projection will be good uh it'll
run into some kind of wall and so what
always happens with these schemes that
are done this sort of idea of remote
control money machine always hits a wall
at some point and then guess what
happens there's a gigantic public
bailout because it's super highly
leveraged because everybody believed in
a totally so there was one of these
fantastic failures of long-term capital
in the '90s
if I remember correctly and uh we're
still paying for that one that was a
huge one but then the I think that one
in a way was forgivable because I think
people went into it with just I mean it
was like me when I was talking before
about the Wonders that we people sort of
were not experienced with it and they
just thought wow it's big it's
computation combined with Statistics
combined with data it's an automatic
money machine you just press this button
and money should come out right it's
automatic so they just believed it and
so then it turned out not to be true the
thing is that afterwards people continue
to do it without learning the lesson so
there's another one a little later
called Enron you guys know about that
one all right and so that one's you're
still playing for that one too um and
and the pattern continues with the the
the Great Recession uh of of U five
years ago very similar pattern uh it
works for time Until It Breaks it's not
too unlike I mean in a sense it's like
traditional market bubbles and failures
the old tulip craze uh markets have
always had this capacity it's just that
if you if you bring big computation
automation into it you amplify it to to
a fantastic degree so that so it's it's
possible to argue that about how how
novel this phenomenon is uh another
company that uh that understood how big
computation could sort of turn on a
spigot of gradual sort of wealth that
that felt guaranteed was uh uh Walmart
Walmart uh did a computational model of
its supply chain in order to optimize to
drive prices down versus its
competitors extraordinary thing so in
the backdrop of seeing all the success
using big computation silicon Valley's
own entrepreneurs had never really
played a game like that we' never uh
said oh we'll just analyze the world to
our advantage and extract a profit from
it we' never done that particular thing
other people had done us done it using
our tools and then um the guy who really
I think first tried it that I ever heard
of anyway was a sweet guy who I still
adore and think is just lovely and he
was a student here Sergey Bren um who
sometimes claims to have had the thought
to impress a date you know how Stanford
women are you have to really come up
with something so uh at least that was
true when I was around here so uh so uh
the the idea was you know we'll get
computation is getting so cheap we'll
give away the services we'll expect to
gather the data that drive the services
for free and then we'll sell advertising
and it sounds really good at first it
sounds sort of like this great scheme
that could just scale forever um what I
have come to believe is that it's
actually a huge mistake um uh nothing
against Google by the way just to say
I'm not anti-google I sold a company to
Google ton of my friends are there I
still feel close to the place so I'm not
anti-g gooogle in any sense but I feel
that and also Microsoft does exactly the
same thing with being we all do it it's
not so it's this is not any in any sense
an anti-google rant but um the thing is
I think that this way of thinking about
the world is self-limiting I think that
it's uh it's based on um math that
self-destruct that predictable moments
uh just like just like the problem that
happens when financiers use computation
naively and believe they have this
automatic money machine um so let me
explain a little bit about why I think
that
um so
uh wow how do I even begin um let me go
back I started a little earlier talking
about musicians as a particular class
and how I felt that employment for
musicians was not enjoying the benefits
that that had been predicted and the
next question to ask is is that an
isolated or exceptional case or does
that pretend something larger for the
economy um if it's if it's exceptional
then we can deal with it as an exception
if it's not exceptional then we have a
bigger problem so I I've come to believe
the latter and so uh there's several
reasons for that but the first one I
think is pretty obvious which is just
that there waves of Technology coming up
that will just throw traditional
employment uh uh you know into into
turmoil and could create mass
unemployment uh waves so I'll just
mention a few of them um I've
participated in the creation of many of
these I'm sure many of you have too
because they all come from right around
here um uh one of them is self-driving
Vehicles which would undo the jobs of
all those cabbies and truck drivers I
was talking about before and the first
one that worked really well was the uh a
Stanford team responding to this the
DARPA Grand ch
uh as so that that came from right here
uh 3D printing is another one 3D
printing kit is currently a hobbyist
thing that makes little knickknacks and
it's not much of anything however in
principle anyone who understands it can
see that it could be refined to the
point where it could be spitting out
future tablets or something uh they
might not be the very best ones but they
certainly could be functional and we can
if we project ahead 10 years 20 years we
start to imagine I think realistically
3D printing creat creating uh fully
functioning mechanisms um the economics
of 3D printing could have extraordinary
efficiencies where you could have hyper
efficient uh recycling because you'd
have records of how something was built
so you could unwind objects that had
been printed uh you'd have um uh
probably a new uh cartel economy around
the antecedants for 3D printing and a
few other dysfunctions but overall it
should create a tremendous increase of
of efficiency um uh another example uh
when people talk about the future of
employment they often say well the kinds
of jobs that will survive are the ones
that are sort of very human touch like
nursing or something like that but the
thing is if you look at the progress in
robotics for nursing uh particularly in
a few hotspots where this is happening
in Japan is a particular is is of great
interest you see incredible progress and
Rapid progress you see and and it's it's
kind of a sensible progress because the
truth is that intensive nursing is
unpleasant work it's analogous to that
horse problem I was mentioning before uh
for similar reasons and
uh and and so it's it's not NE that's
not necessarily a bad thing at all um uh
as anyone in this department knows very
well a lot of jobs that have uh
traditionally required considerable
intellectual effort have are automatable
we know that uh midlevel legal
researchers hey by the way guys I I just
want to say i' I'd love if you have a
question please ask but if you're
Whispering the back it kind of it kind
of is distracting is that okay I'm sorry
I I uh I always give my own students
hell about it so I feel like I should do
it while I'm here too so you can you can
text to each
other you can sit there anyway um so
uh so what we see is uh field after
field where we had assumed uh that uh
you'd need a real person there uh we
have a potential to uh to substitute one
form or another of an information system
um furthermore even in cases where
that's not true we can bring in hyper
efficiencies using information systems
and and a great example of that is mukes
where um I have no doubt that Stanford
and its brand and its desirability would
survive any scenario like this I'm not
so sure about hayward's State across the
bay um I'm not so sure about you know I
mean basically what we could end up with
is very much like um YouTube videos or
something a sort of a power law
distribution with a few institutions
that um draw everybody and then a
massive number of wannabes that go
bankrupt and disappear I view that as
unacceptable with all due respect to to
institutions like Stanford which I value
and you know obviously tremendously but
you know it depends what you think
education is and I can get I this thing
about the future of muks and education
is interesting but I'll I'll leave that
as a separate discussion at any rate in
all of these different areas of human
endeavor you can see that the very
technologies that we love love to work
on the most could create massive
unemployment and yet and yet there's
something fishy going on and and here's
the way I see it if you go back to early
computer science the early computer the
early culture of computer science from
before I was born in the 50s the first
generation of people interested in
artificial
intelligence had no idea what to expect
and and you shouldn't it's not proper to
make fun of reasonable hypotheses from a
earlier era that turned out to be wrong
because I'm positive some of ours and
mine will be turn out to be wrong too
but there was a kind of a sense of um of
incorrectness from a later perspective
because in the first generation of AI
famously there was the sense that if you
could just come up with the right
formula the right compact representation
you could do things like translate
between languages or interpret do all
these things that these days we think of
as being problems that require big data
and statistics right and so there's been
a there's been a transformation of our
assumptions about how to solve certain
kinds of problems but if you go back to
the early days there was this um so uh
my my great mentor when I was a kid was
Marvin Minsky and he'd been part of this
generation who really had thought
initially that you could just come up
with the perfect little parser to to
translate between languages or something
turned out it wasn't an unreasonable
hypothesis but at any rate because our
field started with that idea that sort
of model even though we kind of shifted
to a different technique in order to
actually solve problems and properly so
um something about the ghost of that
original idea still hovers with us and
so um so for instance uh let me go back
to this idea of giving stuff away in
exchange for advertising so uh companies
like Google and Microsoft will be happy
to for free translate a document between
languages so upload in English get back
something in Chinese and it's getting to
be okay it's a little bit shaky but you
know there's often some utility in it
and so so the way this is talked about
in public and the way we tend to present
it is like there's this big electronic
brain and it's translating your
documents for free and what a great
benefit as we all know the way it
actually works is they gigantic corpora
that are scraped constantly from the
internet so that we keep up with changes
in language and we correlate the input
document with these corpora and then
calculate an output and so the thing
about that is that there there are real
translators who are sitting
behind a
curtain and we're pretending that they
don't exist we're pretending so the
thing about anytime you have a big data
solution the key thing to remember the
key Insight here is that there are no
mystical aliens or Angels or sort of
weird supernatural beings that provide
Big Data it all like if there's big data
in somewhere somebody had to do work to
put it there unless it's
invalid
sometimes they do that's true I've seen
that as well so so the thing is there's
always these real people and so there's
a funny there's a funny little
Switcheroo going on here where we're
saying oh here's this giant electronic
brain that we're offering for free to
translate your document but just don't
pay attention to all those people who
provided the example data that turned
into the corpora that's absolutely
essential to it functioning all right so
once you notice that then a pattern
starts to emerge and the pattern is that
um in all the cases and and the
particulars are different in each case
and I I recognize that but in all the
cases where we might see massive
unemployment result from improvements in
Information
Technology there are
also there's also some massive data
collection that depends on people who
are not acknowledged or paid that those
two things go together they don't always
go together to the same degree and there
are exceptions so for instance for
self-driving V Vehicles that's more data
about the world and less creative input
from individuals and so you know so
they're acknowledging that there are
differences in the different cases
there's still a general pattern even in
the case of vehicles around the world
even even in that case there still has
to be that pilot vehicle that's
Gathering Data before the automated ones
do if there's if there's been a big
change and so forth there's still
there's still human labor at the core of
data Gathering it's not the Skyhook that
just takes off on its own you know even
though we might like to pretend it is so
to to my mind if we have a generality in
the nature of the problem of employment
then this provides at least a a a seed
of an approach to A generality and A
solution that addresses it and the
solution would be to pay people who
contribute to
corpora um now before I get I want to go
into a little bit of the history of that
idea because I did not invent that uh
but um I just want to say that the the
the the test that I think should apply
is that um you should ask does a given
data exist because a person exists if
that person did not exist would that
datum still exist and and and that so
that's that's a very broad thing so that
counts for measuring somebody in a
street cam in a way that might lead to
improved efficiency in the sidewalk
design eventually it counts for
somebody's DNA or other biological data
or medical history it counts for their
intentional creative output and for
their unintentional output out through
Behavior measurements of any kind it's a
very broad standard and I believe that
that's the one that would need to be
applied here and I'll get into why in a
second but at any rate let me go into
the history of the idea of paying people
for data that they contribute over a
network
interestingly it was born with the the
very first articulation of how you could
use digital networks to collaborate or
communicate and that's something really
wild and this goes back to Ted Nelson
1960 at Harvard uh when he's a student
so um if we look at the history of um
attempting to visualize what networking
would be like it's very rich in the days
before computers actually existed um if
any of you haven't read the machine
stops by am Forester read it it's like
190708 or something like that and it's a
short story that more or less describes
everything it has Facebook and Skype and
it has hackers and and trolls and it's
just it's really wild um and it was in
that tradition I was talking about it's
part of the same stream of the early
science fiction very similar in a way to
HG Wells um and uh I should mention if
any of you interested in Mark Twain Mark
Twain science fiction is astonishing
about the future of communications and
he he has like Skype like formulations
that are one wonderfully rendered um the
famous piece that most people have heard
of is Van ofar Bush's 40s piece as we
may think which imagined an elaborate
micro fish that included metadata and
traces and all very impressive but as
far as actually think about doing
something with bits and and and and uh
uh and and sort of connected touring
machines as a way for people to do
something together so far as I know Ted
Nelson was the first person to
articulate how that would work and uh he
art so uh he imagined sort of naturally
and for exactly the right reason that
this would be monetized so the idea is
that if somebody puts some bits onto the
network and then somebody else deres
some value of them incorporates them
into something feeds them into a
calculation whatever is there'd be a
micro payment that would feed back to
the person who is the source of the
bids now um Ted Nelson is still with us
he's in his 70s I think and he's living
on a house boo in
souo um Ted is an eccentric beat Nick
guy who is often not his own best
Advocate and can be a little obscure and
difficult on occasions and very
eccentric in his presentation and that's
me saying that uh so it's pretty it's
it's intense and so um that's probably
why his work isn't isn't as well known
he also was had sort of um a
perfectionist Vision where he would get
this group of people to implement the
thing which he called Xanadu for the
most part and they would produce this
perfect Network architecture that the
whole world would adopt and needless to
say it fell apart and nothing was ever
good enough and the whole thing so it
kind of never really shipped one of the
classic stories of how not to ship um so
uh that's why you might not have heard
of him and why you might not be familiar
with his work now the interesting thing
is that in the intervening decades
between the early 60s and when the
internet started to work and then when
the web started to work um during that
period in the 70s and early 80s there
was a kind of a rejection of monetizing
information and it happened in a
culturally strange way um and that I was
around for I was I'm a direct witness to
that phase uh when Ted started this
stuff I was a born you know in 1960 so
that I'm not a direct witness to but
this other phase I was and uh I I'm not
going to go into it in great detail but
um there are a couple of things about
that ER one is that computers were still
pretty slow and and so to to share data
you have to rely on what we used to call
the sneaker net I'm sure some of you
remember which is you'd have to transfer
data to a physical transport medium
which was different in different eras I
mean there was Punch Cards at one point
and
these days you think of a USB stick or
something but you had to you have to
actually physically transfer the
information to something you could move
to another machine um and so during that
period it became very common place to
have osses that could copy files from
here to there to to achieve that however
in the original concept of digital
networking there would be no copying and
the reason why is so obvious which is
that it's already there it's a network
right but because of that sneakernet era
copying became kind of considered normal
now this idea of not copying because
it's still there now I should say the
idea of not copying on a network doesn't
preclude having local caches for
efficiency or having backups for uh for
robustness but in terms for logical
copies they shouldn't be needed on a
well- rot Network right that should be
acatic is that clear somehow it sounds
weird today it used to sound totally
normal um in the 70s when I was a
teenager and I I uh I would worshipfully
visit Xerox Park up the road and in
during the era When Alan Kay was there
and building these amazing prototypes of
the machines that we think of as normal
today uh I remember seeing uh copying in
the in the zarx park prototypes I was
like why are you copying files you just
invented ethernet here you actually can
connect your computers why the hell
don't you use the thing you made why are
you doing this and we pull me over and
and I remember like people like Larry
Tesla wait wait wait we're fun funed by
a copying company you can't you can't
say that copying is going to be obsolete
we will lose our funding don't say that
so that that was another reason why why
uh copying happened um finally there was
a sort of a weird period in the 70s
that's kind of Forgotten which is when
among young technical men especially it
became very popular to be able to be
anonymous in your Communications the
reasons for this were different um uh in
the earliest days of network researcher
research there were kind of two kinds of
network nodes research nodes one would
be military because DARPA was funding it
and one would be academic and so the
academic ones were kind of people who
were freaked out about the Selective
Service System were freaked out about
the drug laws and wanted to be able to
be secretive the uh the military guys
were pissed off that Jimmy Carter had
lowered the speed limit and wanted to be
able to speed with impunity so they were
Avid users of this thing called CB radio
which became the prototype for kind of
idea about internet identity so how many
of you don't know what CB radio
was yeah so this was a thing that was
more present in the culture and perhaps
more Vivid in conversation than Twitter
is today there were popular songs about
it it was this huge thing and what it
was is um you'd get on this radio in
your car and you'd make up a fake name
and You' tell you'd warn other people
where the police were so you could all
Speed without getting without having to
you know deal with the speed limit
Smokey was it's still there it's there
but it's not it's not as present I mean
but but so but so anyway there were all
these this very weird combination of
historical and social circumstances led
to this idea that everything can be
copied with and lose Providence so when
you copy something over a network you
actually lose value because you lose the
Providence and you create inefficiencies
because you're duplicating storage
requirements um so uh losing Providence
is a huge deal I mean more or less
what Google did was try to regain
Providence after the fact that shouldn't
have been lost in the first place and
and something similar can be said about
Facebook because in the original
formulation you'd know who was
interested in your material because
there'd be a direct link um and so this
is all this so this also has to do with
the idea of whether a network has oneway
links or two-way links and I very
vividly remember when Tim burner Lee
proposed the web uh design there had
been all kinds of people trying to do a
networked hyper media design tons of
them there was a there was a a famous
startup right in Paulo Alto I think it
was in PA it was called General magic
that was the original Apple Mac OS team
trying to make something similar to what
turned into the web and there were a
bunch of other ones and everybody was
like you have to have two-way link so
you have Providence and Tim was like ah
Providence is it's like so much work we
could just get so much more rapid spread
and he's absolutely correct about that
it's a very friction free way for things
to
spread were a primary feature of system
and in fact probably caused was the
reason why zanadu was uh uh so slow to
actually get yeah that's probably true I
mean to have back links to have two-way
links requires actual computer science
and not just
hacking it had that but no I mean it's
hard it's hard to maintain it is
hard
doing doing back links means you have to
manage your whole network like a lisp
system or something it's it's not
actually Ward Cunningham is trying to
address this right now with wiks yeah
yes absolutely but in my opinion it has
to be done more
universally um and um uh I think I even
have a a UN resolution now that nobody
will ever read again to
to anyway um we ended up with this world
of uh one-way links for the most that
dominate we ended up in a world with uh
unconfirmed identities we ended up in a
and you so it's it's this different
world and it's this world where
information is assumed to not be
contextualized where we assume we don't
have Providence and so
um ah so
um the problem I have with that is that
if we go from where we are with all of
these waves of new technology that I am
still as enthusiastic about as ever I I
I'm a very strong believer in
self-driving vehicles for instance my
mom died in a car accident I think
people are terrible drivers I want I
want our cars not to hit each other
anymore all right I mean just like that
that's just it's that simple so that has
to happen that's not an option that's a
necessity um uh Manu uh 3D printing is
also a necessity we can our our current
manufacturing practice of of going
anywhere in the world where people work
for less and then having this enormous
movement of raw materials and products
on these huge ships around just to do
that it's just moronic you know we can't
keep doing that that's like a stupid way
to run a world so these things are
necessary they're good however obviously
we have we have a problem with
employment in that world so um some of
my friends
uh I would say I have a lot of friends
who tend to either a sort of a
Libertarian extreme or a lefty extreme
who aren't bothered by this um the
leftists say this is great if there's
massive unemployment it'll finally Force
the Revolution and I'm like we had the
revolution in the 20th century they did
it in Russia and China it really sucks
bad let's let's learn from that instead
of let's not have that one again we did
it it
sucks no you know like like if you can't
accept that an experiment has taken
place and generated a result you you've
really got a problem like you've got to
be able to see that but then the
Libertarians also have a little bit of a
strange um this this attitude that even
if structurally you you create a society
that's based on a power a power law
where only a few succeed well and
everybody else is and wannabes it
doesn't matter because and there are a
couple of ways that this is explained
away one way is to say our technology
will get so good and cheap that even the
people at the bottom will do well
they'll be the one you know there'll be
in exchange for an ad to go to a cafe
there'll be a free robot that does your
heart surgery or whatever um and so
there's that that that sort of attitude
or uh a sort of like well the people who
aren't really contributing don't deserve
to be part of it anyway and this sort of
let let them fail kind of a thing which
I I I just think is phony because we do
rely on their data for what we do it's
just not true you know um yeah how long
do you think large quantities of new
data will be necessary to provide basic
goods and services that are good enough
right so that's a that's a point I go
into in my book so
um presumably for any given digital
service there's some threshold point
where it becomes at least commercially
viable because it has enough data and
then other data might refine it but so
for instance I I think the corpora we
have for machine translation between
languages are probably need to grow I
don't think they're adequate yet but at
some point the thing will start to it's
it's performing better and better so we
could say it's ASM totically approaching
some sort of an acceptable level and
then at that point you might say well we
have the data so there two answers to
that question about the long-term value
of adding to corpora one answer is that
presumably there'll be other Digital
Services and this actually is a crucial
point where I think that um there there
would probably be quite a distribution
of ways that people provide value over
different times and over somebody's
lifetime they might at different times
be contributing to different corpora in
different ways so I'm displaying a kind
of um if you like a Libertarian faith
that there would be Innovation there
would be more things and we won't just
come to this one set of C circumstances
and say hey technology is done we've
done it we're happy we're you know I
don't see that happening that's Marxist
fantasy of the The Lawns right I don't
see that but the other thing I'm
proposing in the book and this gets into
more detail is that the price of
information in a genuine open market
where buyers and sellers have genuine
mobility and where there's a genuine
Market Dynamic should create an effect
where the price for adding data uh data
to a corpora actually values that data
more as the Kora approaches completion
and so I use this crazy metaphor in the
book but I'm just going to use it with
you now let's consider um the Stone Age
and there's like some cave guy who comes
out of a cave and grunts all right and
um uh you might say well how much did
that guy get paid for grunting I like no
everybody's grunting who cares that's
not worth anything you don't pay
somebody to grunt but these days in
specialized circumstances a movie star
might get a million bucks per grunt
according to depending on the script
right so in context this a particular
grunt might actually be worth quite a
lot and and I'm thinking of Arnold
Schwarzenegger our our former Governor
but anyway but the point I I actually
did find some cases where people made a
million dollars a grunt okay so so so
the thing is it's all it's very
contextual you can't if you're going to
believe in market dynamics you can't um
assume the price in advance you have to
let the dynamic determine it so what I'm
thinking is that in a um there should be
a sort of a curved space effect the the
the the underlying metric should be
based on on uh there should be there
would probably be a scarcity of improve
of data that improves a corpora after a
certain point
and the price per datm should start to
go up then instead of down and I believe
that uh in the overall system I'm
proposing that would happen so I think
what would start to happen is there
might be windfalls for people who can
grunch a stride or provide that one
little example that gets used now
there's a lot of subtlety in what I'm
talking about that might not be apparent
at first so for instance I'm proposing
that whenever a uh uh a cloud algorithm
is functioning it has to estimate the
value of contributions of each person's
work and particular corpora uses and and
that might sound like a big job
however what we're doing now is crazy I
mean like if you look at this world
where there are these thousands of
companies trying to step on each other
to be the intermediaries for marketing
data to just send you some ad for stupid
Cafe and the whole economy is around who
can block who and where Google has to
pay blackmail money to add block to get
its ads through it's all this it's like
what we're doing right now is massively
complex and and nutty and I think um
compared to what we're building I think
the thing I'm proposing actually could
be simpler but it's not simple it's it's
it's it's rather complex and there's a
lot of there are a lot of really
interesting algorithmic subtleties about
when you can compute values when you
can't and how you deal with that and all
so I I don't want to even supposing you
could what I'm more curious about is is
what will compensate the children of
2050 for I mean right now the data are
extremely valuable let's suppose and
let's suppose we could do the
attribution problem and compensate
people by your model you know this out
50 years new here's the way i' put it
let's say it's 50 years from now okay
and people have a choice they can become
complacent with some Technology based
and they say our cars drive themselves
our products are
printed we have no wants there's no need
for Innovation that to me is a sort of a
static and
unhappy end to the process of of
civilization and technological
Improvement what I'd rather those people
are saying wow there must be some room
for Innovation here I'm going to come up
with something new that makes it even
better I'm going to whether something
else is going to happen and so what I
hope is that that this creates an
incentive for that but I I I want to be
very careful here because I don't want
to pretend that I have some utopian
complete solution here however I do
believe that the this
tendency actually if I I I I remember
you have a question but I want to go
back to your maybe another way to
approach this question is let me answer
another question that I often hear and
and which is similar um but it's
um it's U it's in the present and that
is people will say what about the
problem that most people wouldn't
provide any anything of value right um
what about the problem that most that
most people aren't creative and that and
that's a really interesting that's an
interesting comment and what I always
say to those people is you might be
right but you might not be so let's keep
an open mind about the distribution of
value in an information economy because
we don't know and I there's some
evidence that ordinary people are
already providing data that's valued by
markets as being remarkably valuable
even though they don't see that value
themselves and you're hopeful that that
match can be but let me yeah but let me
let me let me just say two things about
present value the first thing is um one
of the projects I'm trying to formulate
now and it's hard I would be doing it
already if I had all the answers about
how to how to create an experimental
methodology that we really think is
robust and can defend but right now
there are a lot of techniques one could
use to measure how much data from
Somebody's Worth um one way is to look
at what third party intermediates uh
value the data at and so there and there
there all this whole world of marketing
people that are like I say stepping on
each other's toes and blackmailing each
other to try to get between your data
and somebody who is willing to pay for
it it's a crazy insane scene but there
are other measurements for instance when
you uh pay less because you sign up for
somebody's frequent buyer program you
use a card when you shop for groceries
or when you get a plane ticket you're
entering into their information system
and they view that as valuable and a
portion of that is the value of your
information now a portion of it is
locking you into something so you you're
you're they're paying you to reduce your
Mobility um but those two things are
somewhat fungible I'd argue in the big
picture at any rate um there's a there's
a method that you can start to calculate
and in just some early rough cut
estimates
so I've tried to come up with uh this
imaginary person who I call the most
boring person in the world he's the
opposite of that guy in the beer
commercials who's the most interesting
man in the world he's the most boring
person in the world and whenever I'm at
Stanford I when when I'm at Berkeley I
say it's a Stanford student so here I'll
say it's a it's a Berkeley student and
um it's a and this is the person whose
data means the least to anyone um that
person just based on the sort of Market
standards that have come up for valuing
people's information is probably already
generating bits worth a few hundred a
year now and uh and it appears to be
going up and a very interesting thing is
that is like does it Plateau out at some
level and what is that level and the
really interesting question to me is
might it intersect the poverty line
because if that level intersects the
poverty line then we have a whole new
way to think about creating a society uh
that's not redistributive that's not
socialist but anyway um the the the
thing I want to point out is that every
time there's a new wave of what we might
call automation or hyper efficiency
through digital systems there's a new
value placed on the information from
people so each one of those also values
that information is being higher and
higher now another thing I want to point
out is that some people say well if you
start paying people aren't you just
taking money away from entrepreneurs or
something and the thing the thing that
really bugs me about this is that people
who believe in market economies will
freely move back and forth between
biases towards zero sum or nonzero sum
thinking
without noticing that they're making
that transition so if you believe in
non-zero Sun benefits from market
economies which I think is a very well
Justified belief based on the history of
of of such economies then no the point
of this is you're creating economic
growth and then there's another way to
put this that's even more concrete which
is um right now by not valuing corpora
data in a in an economy that's being
increasingly driven by Cloud algorithms
what you're saying is you're throwing a
bunch of the value of the economy off
the books you're saying we won't have an
accounting for this value so the more
advanced our technology gets the more
the value that goes into that is not
accounted for in our economy so
therefore we see a a slowing of economic
growth when we're actually getting
better at technology which should be
reflected in a growing economy so in a
way the easiest way to put this is to
say let's make our accounting more
complete right and so in a sense that's
all I'm saying
so and it's absolutely true and another
way to address your concern is if the
world starts to really be run
automatically by some machine like in
many science fiction tales and people
don't have to do anything yeah there'd
be a problem a lot of them wouldn't get
paid uh and that's the future where you
have your socialist Revolution I guess
however if we enter into a world where
people are still striving still looking
for Value still looking for difference
still creative then I don't think we
enter into that scenario um I think you
were next so I'll do you you you then
you and then you I'll take
my so how does the fact IDE
done how does the fact that the
government I.E the NSA and the homeland
security places have a copy of it all
enter into the
equation yeah so um the first thing to
say I'm sure many people in this room
have had some contact with the NSA
because they have a very nice math
Institute where many of our friends work
and um every contact I've had with that
world has made me feel the same as I
feel about Silicon Valley that it's very
youthful and very sweet and my my
tendency is to like them and trust them
but of course we have to be concerned
about who could inherit their powers um
and uh uh I say very similar thing about
science fiction I have I I I don't I I I
think we're very we're blessed with an
unusually good-natured Elite in Silicon
Valley but who will inherit it Facebook
is a giant public corporation controlled
by one person which is a really weird
thing in itself but some that means
there's a position for somebody to
inherit and when there is such a thing
that people who are successful
inheriting it are often not great so one
worries about the setup here anyway um
uh in my view the
NSA has made a mistake and their mistake
is exactly the mirror of what Silicon
Valley did and what the financiers did
which is they see the value in Cloud
algorithms and because they by
definition will tend to work a lot first
they are mistakenly thinking that they
have this automatic security nozzle that
they can turn on and calculate security
and the science is bad behind that it
doesn't really work that way um and so I
think I think there's this something for
nothing automatic benefit kind of
thinking that overtakes a lot of people
because initially it is like that when
you have big Computing U it just doesn't
last and so uh I'm concerned that
they're fooling themselves in that
particular way I think there are a lot
of of very fine smart people there um
unfortunately the mathematicians do not
run it they only work for the people who
run it and so um I would rather see the
NSA run by the mathematicians who I
think are smarter than the people who
are paying their salaries in that case
but um such as often the case yes so um
the IDE the fact that that U all kind of
stupid systems are in place for
rewarding people is isn't new I mean
Homemakers haven't gotten credit for
for example for a long time and
uh and so I just wonder it seem to me um
uh and and and Ted Nelson has been
advocating micro payments as I would
call so how do you
transition uh to a logical system how do
you get people to say okay you know
we're not going to change on January 1
how are you going to how are you going
to get there from here is yeah so uh
first I used the example of Homemakers
in in the book as one exam as a metaphor
um so I think it's it's exactly right
you've absolutely asked me the hardest
question and I'd expect that's what I
would expect you to
do easy to write a
book I did not say it was easy no I was
saying it in the spirit of I can't
believe what I did to myself it was not
easy at all I it was torture I can't
even you know I have a a friend who's a
wonderful physicist he just sold his
first book and like oh did I get the
right Advance do I have the right agent
is my editor good do you like my
proposal say don't worry about those
things you're going to find out what to
worry about very soon when you have to
write the damn thing it's like you don't
even H anyway um so to answer your
question on the transition issue um I
that's by far the hardest question in
this whole sort of uh way of thinking I
go into some ideas admittedly somewhat
vaguely in the book because I I view
this as a very early phase in thinking
about this stuff one of the ideas I
propose is what I call economic avatars
which is a way of using um uh using
networking to give people a
psychological way of understanding their
role in the economy that matches what
they're used to that can be interpreted
in different ways now it had one of the
things to say about economics is that
market economies have always depended o
on um gimick on on what you could call
customy and gimmicky and fictions and
whatnot for instance when there's a sale
say oh I got a bargain well not really
you just pay the price that was working
in the Market at that like there's no
such thing as a sale I mean it just
doesn't it's a it's a it's a
psychological Ploy and uh um don't even
get me started by Groupon oh my God but
uh anyway you know so so we we we lie to
ourselves and um I another neighbor uh
on the other side in Berkeley is Danny
canaman who's one of the pioneers of
bringing psychology into economics and
recognizing that if you assume that all
the actors in an economy are rational
will not model that economy accurately
because people are not necessarily
rational and so um what I'm proposing is
um in a sense extending what has been
necessary for people who are retailers
or really any kind of service provider
or Goods seller in the past and to
create um fictions but ones that are are
viable and so uh for instance I I talk
about a scenario where somebody thinks
of themselves is still living in in one
regime where they're not getting paid
for their information they get stuff for
free but I leave that over time
eventually the balance would work out in
their favor if they switched and they
would get this little notice saying hey
you know you've been doing this for a
while if you want to start thinking in
the new way you're owed some money but
you know it's up to you um the other
thing I feel very firmly about this is
that a transition has to have many more
winners than losers it has to be win-win
as much as possible um and I I want to
be clear that I'm not a socialist or you
know I I'm I'm very fond of my friends
who've done well in Silicon Valley
Silicon Valley has treated me extremely
well
um just for what it's worth if anybody's
counting I've sold companies that are uh
parts of adobe Google Oracle and fiser
so I'm a Serial startup entrepreneur as
well as the other stuff I love success I
have no objection to it and I love the
idea of a distribution of outcomes where
the society makes room for high
performance people all of that makes
total sense to me um so uh but um what I
what I do think is that
um the
people the society needs to have
something like a normal distribution of
outcomes in order to be sustainable it
doesn't have to be perfectly that but if
you don't have a big hump in the middle
you can't have your politics uh remain
uncorrupted you can't have customers for
your market economy and uh I can go over
other theories about what makes a
society work but all of them are ruined
if the distribution deviates too much
from normal and so um what uh what I
think is if you um
you know what I just talked myself into
forgetting my thread so my apologies for
that but um anyway but the economic
Avatar is one potential answer I have
some other ideas as well that I proposed
in the book this idea like like you said
before of the uh of having your your
Safeway card or
something where everybody thinks they're
getting a
reward uh instead of a
salary uh is a transition mechanism it
could very well be I mean the problem
with the BART we have this sort of fake
barter economy now where people say oh I
I'm getting benefits that aren't money
I'm getting um I'm getting lower cost
rides because of uber I'm getting lower
cost education because of muks I'm
getting lower cost whatever because of
Groupon I'm getting lower cost groceries
because of my Safeway card and the
problem with all those things is that it
always puts you in a diminished role in
the market you're never first class
citizen you're always accepting the deal
given you never have Mobility or an
ability to negotiate so what it does is
it ruins the Symmetry that's needed uh
to have a market economy and that's and
that's precisely so that results in turn
in a um extreme an extreme wealth
concentration and uh an income
inequality that's another thing I didn't
get into but one of the things that's
really bugged me is um we've been more
part of the problem and part of the
solution in preserving the middle
classes and developed
societies three three three more minutes
before the video stops so but then you
can do the really cool stuff there
should be a reward for being live oh so
this is the video part yeah um and I
feel like I have so if I only have few
more minutes let me just say I feel like
I've only barely scratched the surface
on this body of thought and the book was
written quite quickly and it also is
only barely a scratch but um research is
continuing um I won't embarrass him now
but a graduate student from the
Department worked with me as an intern
over the summer on on building some mod
models of some aspects of it so we're
trying to make things more formal and
more robust and
uh uh it's a process and um I should
also say something about my my
expectation for time frame I think the
time to figure this out is between now
and a couple decades from now I don't
think this has to be fixed tomorrow I
think this has to be fixed before the
masses of uh massive waves of
unemployment would come about from
improved technology so we have a little
bit of wiggle room but now's a good time
to start sorting it out I also don't
think that the ideas been talking about
are necessarily the only way to approach
it there's some others that are have
some similarities and some differences
that could also be talked about uh I'm
not ideological or adamant that I know
the right way or anything like that um I
am adamant that the existing ways that
everybody talks about like when somebody
says oh um we're improving the future of
our economy by with social networking or
something I don't think that works I
think that just concentrates uh um money
with whoever has the biggest computer
this is actually the final point I'll
make one of the ideology IES that drove
me tremendously in the Decades of
anticipation before all this stuff
started to work was that if information
was open it would be this great
equalizer where all kinds of people
would be empowered and the thing that I
realized too late is that if everybody
has access to information openly it does
not create equal opportunity because
some people have more effective
computers than other people so the truth
is that you could go scrape the internet
just like Google I mean it's just out
there just scrape the web you know but
the but you don't have a city-sized uh
server form to process it and so um you
could also calculate your way to a
seemingly perfect Market position but
you don't have the big computation and
the hookup to do high frequency trading
you know so the per those with there's a
huge differential in how powerful and
how effective computers are based on
their positioning based on their size
based on the people who work with them
based on various things but that
differential is gigantic it used to be
that if you look at who the richest
people are in societies around the world
they tended to be closer to either uh
political power an oil field or some
kind of Narrows of trade or something
like that but increasingly around the
world at the United Nations I saw this
when you meet rich people you ask well
what's your what's your gig you know how
why are you this billionaire they're
always close to some big computer
increasingly they're like oh I run the
trading system here or or I'm I'm
running the cell network here or I'm
running the Giant ad exchange or the
social networking in this giant emerging
economy or something like that it's
everybody's always close to some
computational thing so um that's
obviously not a sustainable way to run a
civilization um I think with that yeah
thank you and applaud sure and I will
get your
question